in response to russia's aggression in
ukraine finland and sweden formally
apply to join the military alliance
known as nato this morning presenting
their application letters formally to
the alliance's secretary general in
brussels meanwhile on the ground in
ukraine there is concern building for
those ukrainian fighters who were
defending that steel plant in mariupol
russia says nearly 1 000 of them have
now been taken into russian controlled
territory after what moscow says was a
mass surrender they were seen being
loaded onto buses before being driven
away deborah patta has more now from
inside ukraine
these are the men
and women who held off russian forces
for 83 days depleted worn out
loyal to the end the last stand is over
their fate uncertain as they are not
free held in russian-controlled
territory
ukraine is negotiating a prisoner swap
as mario pool falls the ukrainian flag
still flies proudly over har kiev
after more than two months of fierce
fighting russia has been pushed back to
the border the bloody battle scars
litter the roads
shows me the shrapnel she found in her
garden after russian troops retreated
but not far enough we heard the sounds
of war throughout our interview but you
have no electricity
there's sound
that's constant right
it's very very scary she says
it's very noisy here so
it must be stressful
it's stressful she says on a whole other
level
it was winter when the russians invaded
she and her husband had no heating
azabolila
i was very ill she remembers sobbing i
was under four blankets and i was still
freezing
finally spring has arrived
[Applause]
and good for the soul water she says
is life
two people died in her street during the
russian occupation those deaths together
with thousands more alleged atrocities
will be investigated by the
international criminal court which is
sending its largest ever field team to
ukraine nate
deborah patta with boots on the ground
in ukraine thank you